Das Podcast-Dufon mit Sterrentin Will und ne was?
Audi, herzlich willkommen zu diesem wilden Ritt durch den wilden, wilden Westen, angeführt von unserem Treibpferd Leon.
Und natürlich, hinten auf dem Sattel schwingt sich natürlich der schnellste ... Florentin Will und dahinter, da ist dann so ein Seil und dann so ein Brett. Und da drauf sitzt der Guido. Und dann ist noch ein weiteres Seil an diesem Brett und das Pferd denkt sich, was mache ich eigentlich? Ja. Und da drauf sitzt sich Stefan Tietze. Der meistgesuchte Mann des Westens, Stefan Tietze, der schnellste Finger Mexikos. Und damit meine ich nicht Pistolen. Geil, caramba, muy caliente, muy fuego. Si, si. Ja, herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast UFO.
Mit, ihr habt es schon gehört, Stefan, Tietze, man duzt ihn nicht, man tietzt ihn.
Nice, und Florentin will.
Jetzt will ich keinen fucking Gag mit deinem direktes Nachnamen machen.
Tu es, tu es.
Spüre die Macht in deinen Fingern. Man möchte ihn nicht, man will ihn nicht.
Ja!
Do it! Do it! Unlimited Power! Damit ist Stefan offiziell auf der dunklen Seite. Wenn man keinen Geschmack mehr hat, sondern einfach jeden Gag macht, hat man auf eine Art Unlimited Power. Ja, genau. Willkommen bei Folge... Willkommen als Podcast-Jubel. Folge 404, Comedy Not Found. found. Leon hat das Intro geschickt, vielen Dank für diesen kleinen, einen Mann mit seiner Gitarre, ich mag das ja immer gern. Ich mag das auch immer gern. Klar, ich gehe gerne ins Orchester, höre Stradivaris Vierte und all das, ich höre das gerne. Fragst du dich auch immer, Mann mit teurer Gitarre und billigem Mikrofon oder Mann mit billiger Gitarre und teurem Mikrofon? Das frage ich mich immer. Das denke ich mir immer. Oder, oder, Mann mit teurer Gitarre, teurem Mikrofon oder Mann mit billiger Gitarre und teurem Mikrofon. Das frage ich mich immer. Das denke ich mir immer. Johnny Cage ist ja ...
Mann mit teurer Gitarre, teurer Mikrofon und billiger Schnittsoftware. Oder teure Gitarre, billiges Mikrofon und teurer Mann. Oder, jetzt wird es kompliziert, dann müssen wir so eine Matrix gleich in Matrix aufstellen, Matrizen, teurer, teures Mikrofon, billige Gitarre, wenig Talent, teures Schnittprogramm, aber auch hier, wenig Aufnahmetalent, Freund, der noch geholfen hat, mit sehr viel Talent, gleicht sich also aus, Nullen, können wir wegstreichen. Teures Tonstudio, billige Gitarre, teure Saiten auf der Gitarre, also ne, das ist die Frage. Schlechtes Stimmgerät. Und guck mal, als Musikfan könnte ich mich über sowas stundelang unterhalten. Ich würde jetzt gerne nichts lieber tun, als mit dir abends ... Was für ein Glück, dass du es nicht bist, dass du kein Musikfan bist. ... mit dir bei so einem Schalenbier in irgendeiner WG-Küche um halb drei einfach mal die Zeit vergessen und über Quatsch reden. Schales Bier, da da da ist mein gehirn stecken geblieben so dass ich nicht mehr dazuhören kann nennen wir denn top fünf schalen biere das ja ich glaube dann man muss ja bier immer auf so ein gewisses schalen niveau einträgen also wenn wir wenn wir aufgemacht wird wenn die korken knallen dann ist es ja eher wenn die Bierkorken knallen. Die Kronkorken knallen. Wenn die Bierkorken knallen, ist es erstmal nicht gut ein, zwei Schlücke, dann ist das Bier so schal, wie ich's haben will. Schales Bier trinke ich da und hier und überall. Und dieser Song hat mir quasi alles beigebracht, was ich über Bier weiss, deswegen erstmal mal Schal trinken und dann genießen. Schal, ich glaube, geschmackslos wäre die Definition, oder? Abgestanden. Ich benutze Worte, deren Bedeutung ich nicht kenne. Same. Ebenso. Können wir statt Same ebenso gleichfalls sagen? Ja, nee, ich auch. Ich bin unverständlich, weil ich nicht kenne. Ich soll über den Elephant in the room, den Elefanten im Raum sprechen. Ja, komm. Ich war im Urlaub. Genau, Stefan war im Urlaub. Du warst unterwegs. Im Urlaub. Habt ihr gar nicht mitbekommen, weil wir das so clever ... Dein Instagram-Post war ja nicht zu übersehen. Nee, der jetzt schon ... Also, das haben wir ja dann durchaus schon mitbekommen, weil es ist ja dann doch so, dass das Privat dann doch nicht ganz geht, ne? Naja, ja. Okay, muss ich mir gefallen lassen, diese Kritik, ich weiss nicht, in welche Richtung sie geht. Es ist Neid, es ist Neid. Auf Neid. Stefan, ich bin doch neidisch. Sorry, da muss ich jetzt auch mal alle Hüllen fallen lassen. Privat geht's dann doch nicht. Ich möchte mich direkt entschuldigen, weil ich bin natürlich nur neidisch, was du da Tolles erlebt hast. Erstmal diese herrliche Freundschaft mit dir und deinem Kumpel. Also allein das mit diesem, wie du mit deinem R2D, mit so einem kleinen Roboteroter, der irgendwie immer an deiner Seite ist und der über Stock und Stein fährt mit dir. Und das ist eine tolle Freundschaft. Ja, kleiner Funfakt, neben mir sieht jeder aus wie ein kleiner R2D2. Ja, das stimmt natürlich, aber es ist natürlich eine Freundschaft, auf die ich einerseits neidisch bin, andererseits natürlich die körperliche Leistung, du bist wahnsinnig viel gewohnt. Aber dabei sind wir auch doch schon zusammen, haben die Welt verreicht. Ja gut, wir saßen in New York im Subway und du wurdest von einem Fremden angegrabbelt. Das ist was anderes, als wenn man gemeinsam durch den Dschungel auf den Berg geht. Nee, es war sehr cool. Wir waren drei Wochen in Kolumbien. Es war cool. Kolumbien? Si, Kolumbia. Wohl eher Kolumbien. Ja, das denke ich aber auch. Das denke ich aber wirklich auch. Ich liebe Kolumbien. Ich liebe Kolumbien. Und da, ja, du hast es erwähnt, angesprochen, wir haben da eine Wanderung durch den Dschungel gemacht, das war cool. Aber man sagt gar nicht Klumbien oder so, ne, man verkürzt es nicht. Man sagt immer Kolumbien komplett. Dann bist du da wirklich auch böse angeguckt, wenn du das verkürzt. So wie Schland, also dass du jetzt nicht immer die Mühe machst, sondern also wäre Klombien das Schland-Äquivalent zu Kolumbien.
Und das heisst, wenn Kolumbien jetzt die WM gewinnen sollte, sollte Gewände mit zwei Asterix-Sternchen mal dabei. Mit Asterix und Obelix. die beide in der Legende nachzulesen sind, nur eine Vermutung, nur eine Spekulation muss so nicht sein.
Der Rechtsweg bleibt offen.
Und deswegen tatsächlich, wenn Kolumbien tatsächlich gewinnen sollte, was grölen wir dann? Kolumbien.
Kolumbia. Die werden nicht Kolumbien sagen.
Die werden nicht die deutsche Aussprache ihres Landes bevorzugen bei Fangesängen. Vielleicht doch, weiss ich nicht. Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie sagen würden, Kolumbia, Kolumbia. Aber es, also Columbia mit C, und wir haben daraus Columbien gemacht.
Ja, okay. Ich glaube, wir haben uns vertan. Hm? British Columbia. Da waren wir noch gedanklich. Ach so. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich ... man hat sich wirklich vertan. Puh, jetzt werden die ... Jetzt werden die Hände desinfiziert, das ist jetzt der Moment. Ja, ich hab jetzt ... Das ist jetzt genau der Moment. Das ist jetzt genau der Moment. Ich hab's jetzt entdeckt. Das kannst du strategisch in dem Gespräch sehr fein anwenden, diesen Move, dass du mitten im Gespräch sagst, ja und dann wollte ich sie anrufen, sie ist nicht rangegangen. Und dann, was ist dann ... okay, was? Ja, es sieht nämlich so aus, ob du mich a operieren willst, b umbringen willst. Ob jetzt die Stelle in der Anekdote kommt, wo jetzt regt sie den Rest der Folge hier einfach nach gesund. Nach Chemiekeule. Was war da jetzt an deinen Händen dran, dass das jetzt unbedingt sterben musste? Die U-Bahn noch. Gut, die hängen jetzt auch schon drei Stunden hier an meinen Händen, aber ich habe sie jetzt erst entdeckt. Ich dachte, das wäre so ein Bildschirmspray. Da dachte ich, ich benutze noch nicht das Bildschirmspray. Und plötzlich sehe ich Händedesinfektionsspray. Du nimmst auch alles in die Hand, was man dir vorsetzt. Du kannst einfach wie so ein Hund, wo man genau weiss, leg dem irgendwas vor, der wird es früher oder später finden. Ich glaube, dich zu vergiften, wäre ein leichtes. Kinderschmied. Also wirklich dich. Ah, nee, nee, weil ich bin da nämlich sehr wie ein Hund. Ich rieche an allem, was ich konsumiere zuerst. Ah, oder würdest du auch sehen, direkt riechen, würdest du sofort wissen, ah, das ist auch ein Buch. Nee, aber ich würde, ja, aber vermutlich, weil wenn du einem Hund eine Zitrone gibst, ich weiß nicht, ob du es mal gemacht hast, aber eine Zitrone hinhältst, in der Hoffnung, weil die ja immer in alles reinbeissen, und man denkt, I got you, diesen Trick, ich werde diesen Joke jetzt spielen, so ein kleiner Prank, hält man diese Zitrone hin und sie beissen nicht rein, sie riechen dran und denken, puh, was ist das? Aber kann man sauer riechen? Was passiert hier? Man kann doch sauer nicht riechen. Säure, kannst du riechen? Nein, du kannst doch sauer nicht riechen. Ich bitte dich, Florentin Will, ich bitte dich, David Pascal Will. Du kannst riechen, Moment, okay, pass auf, nächste Folge, ich bring zwei Hitchis mit, einen sauren Hitchi und einen normalen Fruchthitchi von Hitchler und diese Stangen, diese Kaustangen, diese Kaustangen, ja, okay, ja, diese Kaustangen und du sagst mir, du kannst unabhängig jetzt von den Geschmacksrichtungen den sauren Hitchi am Geruch vom normalen Hitchi erkennen, weil du sauer riechen kannst. Das ist wirklich deine Aussage. Stefan Tietze aus Carmen wettet. Bist du dir hundertprozentig sicher, dass du dir den Satz tätowieren lassen willst, man kann Säure riechen? Ja. Gut, dann machen wir es. Das machen wir nächste Woche. Ja, bricht zwei Hitchis mit in so einer Schatulle, in so einer Edelmetallschatulle. Wo die schon drei Tage dann drin waren. Wo so ganz fein eingraviert wurde, KB. Keine Bange. Und immer wenn ich dieses Etui raushol, die Leute gucken dann auch manchmal so, was ist das KB, und dann denken sie im Kopf nach so K... K... Aber niemand traut sich nachzufragen, weil es wirkt so, als sei es so ein Familienerbstück. Es wirkt offensichtlich. Cornelius Buchmann. Es ist Cornelius Buchmann am Ende. Ja, machen wir dann in neuen Folgen, wenn du daran denkst und oder die Zeit gefunden hast. Werde ich wahrscheinlich vergessen. Was ich niemals vergessen werde, ist dein Urlaub in Kolumbia. Du warst in Kolumbia, du hast jetzt gesagt, mal so lapidar nebenbei, hast du gesagt, du bist durch einen Dschungel gewandert. Genau, wir haben, man kann nämlich, das ist richtig toll, das ist auch der Grund des Trips gewesen, man kann da durch den Dschungel wandern um dann die verlorene Stadt, die verlorene Stadt Kolumbiens, die ist sogar noch älter als Machu Picchu und wirklich so ein bisschen so ein Indiana Jones Ziel. Was heisst verlorene Stadt? Die heisst La Ciudad Perdida, Ciudad Perdida, die verlorene Stadt. Die hat man an den Dschungel verloren, die hat man erst irgendwann, jetzt weiss ich nicht mehr genau, weil es war alles auf Spanisch die ganze Tour. Auch die Zahlen., es wurde wohl, glaube ich, erst in den Sechzigern oder so entdeckt, siebzigern. Also die hatten eine … Vielleicht später. … eine brummende Metropole und dann aber eines Tages kamen die Ranken, kamen die Blätter, kamen die Leoparden, die Geparden und haben einfach die Stadt übernommen. Ja, es kamen die … So eine grüne Lawine. Es kamen die Konquestadoren, es kamen Krankheiten, es kam Leid. In den Sechzigern? Ä, ne, viel früher. Ach so, ich meine die 1560er, sorry, hätte ich dazu sagen sollen. So, ich dachte, dass wir ein Grundwissen haben. Ich dachte, während Woodstock, dass die letzten Conquestadoren kommen. Da wurden die entdeckt wieder. Ach so, die wollten im Dschungel... Das ist mir gefallen, wann die entdeckt wurde, habe ich ja 70er. Jetzt verstehe ich es, die wollten im Dschungel Woodstock feiern und haben nach dem Location gesucht und haben die Stadt verlassen. Sie haben sich durchgehackt, Krankheit, Terror, Leid. Die wollten zu Woodstock. Die ganze Stadt ist geschlossen nach Woodstock gefahren und danach war die Stadt von den Ranken erobachtet. Auch wenn da alle so aussahen, wie als würden sie Burning Man feiern, haben die damit nichts zu tun. Wir haben nicht für ein Festival und Woodstock haben nichts zu tun. Jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Jetzt habe ich verstanden, was du meinst. Jetzt habe ich verstanden. Als ich nichts gesagt habe, sondern nur, dass es nichts mit Woodstock zu tun hat. Jetzt habe ich es, sorry, jetzt habe ich alles. Das war dein einziges Problem. Jetzt habe ich es komplett verstanden. Jetzt habe ich es komplett verstanden. Woodstock war in Nordamerika, Kolumbien ist in Südamerika. Sieben. Kolumbia ist Südamerika. Und damals in den 1500 Jahren waren die beiden Erdhälften zusammen, sodass die sozusagen auf der einen Seite Shakehand, Flyby, Richtig. Okay, alles klar. So, und da haben die diese Stadt, haben die komplett verlassen, die Indigenen, die Tairona, haben das verlassen.
Tairona?
Tairona.
Haben das verlassen und sind, haben die dann dem Dschungel überlassen und sind woanders hingezogen, haben diese Stadt als verflucht angesehen, da sind viele Menschen gestorben.
Und dann wurde es irgendwann entdeckt, diese Stadt wieder, und jetzt seit ersten paar Jahrzehnten kann man da dann hinreisen, aber, und das ist das Schöne daran und das Abenteuerliche daran, ist es nicht wie Machu Picchu, einfach ein Ort, wo man einfach hinfahren kann, auch theoretisch mit dem Bus oder Bahn, sondern man muss da drei Tage lang hinwandern durch den Dschungel. Und es war wirklich richtig cool. Es war eine atemberaubende, super schwierige, aber coole Wanderung, wo man halt abends in so Camps schläft.
Also da gibt es schon so ein bisschen Infrastruktur für diesen Weg. Es gibt halt so Holzverschläge, in denen man dann letztlich schläft. Kann ich mir nichts darunter vorstellen? Ich mein, also so, ja, so überhaupt, es ist Material, was man aus Bäumen gewinnt, Verschläge.
Ah, okay. Alles klar.
Dann kann man darin so pennen, so Moskitonetzen. Und das ist auch sehr faszinierend, man schläft dann meistens, man geht die Strecke eigentlich neben so einem Fluss oft lang. Der Fluss ist immer in der Nähe. Und ein paar dieser Camps sind halt an diesem Flusslauf. Und das Wasser ist unglaublich laut. Und man geht, ich mit meinem europäischen Verständnis, oder weiss ich nicht, großstädtischen Verständnis, gehe davon aus, dass es nachts nachtwohl ist. Nachtwohl. Na klar. Nachtwohl hat man die Klasse zu halten. In zehn Uhr ist der Fluss aus. Und der Fluss ballert aber auf Lautstärke 1000 die ganze Nacht durch. Da hilft nur ein laminiertes DIN-A4-Blatt morgens im Flur, der mal sagt, welches Arschloch ist die ganze Nacht wieder durchgeflossen? Sag mal, kann man hier nicht, eigentlich noch passiv aggressiver, kann man hier nicht erwarten, dass man das nachts verdammte Ruhe einkehrt? Nachts ist Flussstille. Und dann Leerzeichen, drei Ausrufezeichen. Ja, genau. Und dann vielleicht auch so ein Facepalm-Emoji. Genau, ja, ja. Und dann drei so Xe. So diese merkwürdigen gelben Emoji-Gesichter, die irgendwie, zu denen normale Leute keinen Zugriff haben, sondern nur stocksaure. Du musst so wütend sein, um Zugriff auf diese zu grossen Emojis mit zu viel Ausdruck. Man muss recht alt sein, vielleicht eine unabgedettete Word-Version, habe ich schon gedacht, haben. Ah, das kann sein, ja, das kann gut sein. Aber die kann man erst freischalten, wenn man sehr sauer ist. Richtig. Und dann hat man diese gelben, 3D-artigen Emojis mit diesen roten Wangen, mit diesen wunderschönen roten Wangen und diesen Augen, die Lust auch aussagen. Du musst die … Wo einem auch manchmal der Knopf aufgeht, wenn der wirklich zu lange in diese Augen schaut. Da geht mir wirklich der eine Hemdknopf auf. Wo man sagen muss, wenn du mindestens 10.000 Ausrufezeichen benutzt hast, dann schaltest du die frei als Achieve mit, dann kannst du die benutzen. Ja, ja. Aber dann hat sich … Ich fand's nur lustig. Also sorry, ich will jetzt gar nicht kolonialistisch klingen, aber das wird es in Deutschland nicht geben. Ein Fluss, der die ganze Nacht durchfließt, an ist und wirklich nicht an die Regeln hält. Also ich finde ja fremde Länder auch spannend. Ich finde es schwierig. Aber da, das könnte ich nicht. Da habe ich fast, ich dachte, es ist der ewige, stundenlange steile Aufstieg, die Hitze, die Luftfeuchtigkeit, die Moskitos. Nein, ich hätte fast die Reislande gezogen wegen des Flusses, der nachts, verdammt nochmal, nicht ausfällt. Ich stelle mir vor, wie du nachts aufwachst, so drei Uhr nachts liegst du im Bett und sagst, so gut, da gehe ich jetzt rüber. Und dann gehst du rüber, holst du so ein paar Stücke Holz und Bauch. Mit so zukreffen Augen und so einem Bademantel. So Bademantel und dann so, Entschuldigung, mit so einer belegten Stimme. Also mal, geht's noch? Auch dieses Flüstern schreiende, also Entschuldigung, jetzt muss ich auch mal sagen, das ist wirklich laut, man hört sie bis in unser Camp rüber. Ja, wir wohnen ganz oben, paar Häuser weiter, und ich höre immer noch die Musik. So. Und am Ende gehst du da hin und baust einfach Damm auf eigene Faust und sagst so, Fluss, Stopp, nach Stopp, Stopp. Am nächsten Tag ist alles überflutet. Und da habe ich mich so kolonistisch vor die Leute gestellt. Grosser weisser Mann bringt Ausschalter. Aber dann, ja, und dann auch, also ich weiß, es klingt total bescheuert, wenn man das jetzt so erzählt, aber man macht sich darüber ja keine Gedanken. Ich habe noch nie nachts neben etwas so Mächtigem geschlafen, was so eine Extreme... War das so ein richtiger reissender Fluss, oder was? Ja, und da waren auch teilweise Wasserfälle und die sind halt einfach wahnsinnig laut. Super laut, ja. Und ich fand das so, ich fand das gar nicht schlimm, ich fand das wirklich ein schönes Geräusch, aber man macht sich darüber tatsächlich keine Gedanken. Ja, ja. Und ich fand das so faszinierend, dann nachts einfach diese Lautstärke, plus die ganzen 90 Milliarden Tiere, die nachts anfangen, ja auch erst Geräusche zu machen. Trottel. Ja, im Ernst, nachts ist es dunkel, da. Hallo, niemand findet euch. Trottel, ey. Die Raubtiere finden euch, weil ihr so laut seid. Äh, schau mal drüber nach, da. Da. Äh, Evolution, hallo. Aber das fand ich sehr faszinierend. Aber der fucking Spielverderber-Ohr wieder, ne? Das Auge, ach, ergötzt sich, labt an diesen herrlichen Landschaften, dieser saftgrünen Wipfel, die Wasserfälle herrlich anzusehen, nachts, so, ähm, ja, ich würde dann jetzt ins Bett gehen, Ohren, ne, also, ich bin die Augen und ich würde jetzt ins Bett gehen, hatten wir schon einen langen Tag und ich würde es jetzt packen, ich mach's, gut nach, tschüss, gut nach, ich leg mich hin, wir bleiben noch ein bisschen auf, ah, okay, dann bis morgen, bleibt ihr noch ein bisschen auf, wir bleiben noch ein bisschen auf, auf. Alles klar, dann bis morgen. Gut nach. Wie so Red Bull trinkende, ewig wache, nervöse. Was war das? Und die Augen ziehen so ihre Lieder über sich und schlafen ruhig ein. Die Augen, die auch immer genau wissen, woher was kommt und die Ohren immer. Was war das gerade? Kann man schon leicht links oder schräg rechts? Ja, nur mit dem anderen Ohr zusammen, die müssen zusammenarbeiten. Gut, die Augen auch. Ja gut, die Augen auch. Die Nase wäre ja nicht. Wohin gegen die Nase wäre scheissegal. Ich finde so, die beiden Augen sind so wirklich so zwei High Performer so. Hast du die Daten? Alles klar? Ja, alles klar. Hast du die Daten? Alles klar? Ich habe eine leichte Verschiebung, zwei Zentimeter. Alles klar. Ich sehe eine Gestalt von links kommen aus dem Pedifil im Durchbereich. Ja, habe ich auch schon gesehen, ungefähr acht Meter Entfernung. Alles klar, wunderbar, kein Problem. Dankeschön, wir gehen schlafen, initiiere Lead-Schliess-Rhythmus. Klar, in drei, zwei, eins, execute. Wohingen die Ohren eher so, Hudi, Hudi, ich hab da was von vorne links und ganz andere Probleme hier. Ganz andere Probleme hier, ich hab ganz andere Probleme. Titus. Titus? Oh shit!
Kommt das von... Dude, hörst du den Hahn?
Keine Ahnung! Hörst du den Hahn?
Ich hab hier ein Auto! Kommt ja von links oder rechts!
Ich hab hier zwei Autos, Udo!
Und währenddessen die Nase... Die Nasenlöcher arbeiten gar nicht zusammen. Das ist so eine Doppelstelle eigentlich. Das ist so ein Typ an zwei Telefonen. Wo gehen die zusammen? Es klingen immer beide. Ich glaube, es ist nach einem Zentimeter. Kurz Witzpause. Okay, Comedy Stopp aus. Wo gehen? Keiner bewegt sich. Wo laufen die beiden zusammen? Nach ein, zwei Zentimeter. Wirklich? Ich glaube, es ist wirklich null Unterschied. Wir könnten genauso gut einen Nahe in der Nase haben.
Obwohl, ich habe ja schon mal das Stereo-Riechen bewiesen, dass du tatsächlich auch Richtungen riechen kannst. Und das ist auch bewiesen worden wissenschaftlich. Der Effekt ist nicht so stark, weil die beiden, wir gucken noch mal zu den beiden Nasenleuten. Bata, Bata!
Roh Popcorn. Nein. Bata, Bata!
Oh, Popcorn mag ich.
Am liebsten ist mir Popcorn-Geruch.
Auch nichts beigetragen mehr.
Das Lächeln wiederholt, was der andere gesagt hat.
Am liebsten isst mir Popcorn.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Also wirklich, die beiden, das sind Imposter, das ist einfach dieselbe Person, die einfach zwei so verschiedene Hüte hat.
So einfach, wenn du sagst, einmal linkes Nasenloch bitte.
Äh, ja, äh, hi.
Ähm, genau, wir haben gerochen, wir haben Kot.
Gerochen. Okay, dann frage ich das rechte? Dann frage ich nochmal das rechte. Ich laufe kurz einmal rum. Ja, hi, hallo. Bekleiden Sie zwei Stellen, um mehr Gehalte zu bekommen? Wie bitte? Ob Sie mehr als eine Stelle bekleiden? Sie müssen mehr kommen. Ich kann Sie nicht wahrnehmen. Ich kann Sie nicht wahrnehmen. Okay, ich stehe wirklich sehr nah schon vor Ihnen. Okay, ja, jetzt habe ich sie, jetzt habe ich sie. Bekleiden Sie zwei Stellen, damit Sie mehr Gehalt bekommen. Nein! Nein! Was ist das für ein ... Nein! Was ist das für ein ... Wie bitte? Ausdruck. Was ist das für ein ... Was ist das für ein ... Was ist das für ein ... Was ist das für ein ... Was ist das für ein... Ich... Okay, Sie lügen. Sie können riechen, Sie können schlecht riechen, aber noch schlechter lügen. So, hier wird ja komplett zusammengekürzt alles, ne? Wir haben ja kaum noch Ressourcen. Jedenfalls, dann war da nachts, war wieder die Hölle los. Ich fand das aber cool. Ich fand es tatsächlich nur, es hat mich so überrascht, die erste Nacht, wie wenig ich darauf vorbereitet war und wie selbstverständlich man von Nachtruhe ausgeht. Fand ich interessant. Und dann trackt man weiter, man läuft durch den Dschungel. Ich will euch auch gar nicht mit den Details belästigen. Das war wunderschön, ja, schaut euch die. Es war absolut wunderschön. Und dann kommt man wirklich so Indiana Jones-mässig an diese Ruine an plötzlich und muss dann noch 1200 Stufen gehen. Die mit ihren Stufen?
Ja, scheiß Stufen. Das ist so das Ding in Südamerika, oder? Stufen. Ja, okay. Fahrstuhl habt ihr noch nicht davon gehört? Oder einfach mal unten bleiben? Wie wär's damit? Ja, warum muss man immer überall hochkraxeln? Ja, aber du sagst es jetzt so locker Dschungel. Wenn ich an Dschungel denke, denke ich an Giftschlange, denke ich an Jaguar, an Panther. Ich glaube nicht. Also hast du Tiere gesehen, gibt's da so Leute so, ey, wenn euch ein Tiger anfällt, dann totstellen, oder gab's da so ein Briefing für die Gefahren, hattet ihr eine Harpune dabei? Es fing mir cool an, weil ein Team wurde uns vorgestellt, man hat so als Gruppe so drei Leute, die da mitlaufen, ein Tourguide, meistens noch ein Übersetzer und jemanden, der dabei ist.
Und basically einfach, genau, wenn es ein spanischer Tourguide ist und dann wird es auf Englisch übersetzt, wir hätten jetzt keinen Übersetzer. Aber es war jemand dabei und dachte direkt, cool, dass wir das machen, ein Typ mit einer Machete. Und da habe ich gedacht, hell yes, der Typ. For guess, here we go. Ich laufe hinter dem Typen mit der Machete. Und dann hat er einmal geschwungen und ich gesagt, ich laufe woanders als der Typ mit der Machete. Und dann, nee, es war cool, das sah cool aus, das hat er nie benutzt, aber tatsächlich... Hat er die so an der Seite getragen, so ein Schwert? Nee, hinten am Rucksack dran, in der Seitentasche, da wo du immer die Wasserflasche drüber hast. Ja, ich hab die Machete im Rucksack, also ich müsste dann bei Angriff nochmal aufmachen. Ich weiss. Nee, aber das fand ich faszinierend. Und ja, das ist so Puma-Gebiet, Panther-Gebiet. Ah, okay. Also sind da mit Jugendgangs gemeint oder das echte Tier? Das echte Tier. Ach so. Dann Papageien sieht man, die haben wir auch gesehen. Ich habe wunderschöne Schmetterlinge gesehen. Ich habe keinen Puma gesehen, leider. Nicht mal gehört, nicht mal gerochen, gar nichts. Generell wenig Tiere. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass diese Strecke inzwischen, obwohl die das sehr regulieren und eine bestimmte Anzahl Menschen da immer rein darf, glaube ich, ist dieser Weg dann doch zubegangen für die Tierwelt da draußen. Ich glaube, da ist das vielleicht nicht so gut für die. Aber das ist schon ein grosser, riesiger Dschungel einfach, oder ist das so ein kleines? Nee, ist schon gross. Schon riesig. Aber du darfst ja drei Tage durch und dann ist auch noch nicht zu Ende. Dann geht es noch weiter. Du könntest dann ewig weitergehen, aber man kehrt dann wieder um. Das ist dann sehr unbefriedigend dramaturgisch, man geht den gleichen fucking Weg zurück, man kann seine Fußspuren theoretisch sehen und dann ist das super anstrengend.
Ja, das ist echt blöd.
Und es ist ja nicht irgendwie, es geht ja nicht hoch, du erreichst dann dein Ziel und dann gehst du komplett wieder runter. Nee, es ist ja die ganze Zeit bergauf, bergab, bergauf, bergab, bergab, man legt schon ein paar mehr Höhenmeter zurück, aber es ist halt ein bisschen unbefrieden, wenn man rückwärts wieder rausgehen muss quasi. Du kannst auf dem Rückweg nicht einfach rollen lassen. Und dann sehr spannend, da leben halt noch Indigene, also mit eigener Sprache, eigener Kultur, die dürfen da leben, wie sie es immer getan haben und es auch… Das ist nett von uns, dass die da leben dürfen, das ist echt nett. Nee, so meine ich das nicht. Es wird … Es ist nur … Ein bisschen würde Sachen passieren auch da. Also sie … Also sowas wie Inzucht wird halt weiter praktiziert, teilweise richtig sehr unschöne Dinge. Von daher muss man das manchmal schon so sagen, weil es nicht so … Wann greift man da ein? Es geht wirklich nicht mit den Werten, es geht nicht mit humanitären Werten, die man in der Welt eigentlich hat, zusammen. Die gehen auch ganz, ganz schlecht mit den Tieren um zum Beispiel und so. Von daher muss man schon sagen, es gilt auch nicht, das Gesetz von Kolumbien wird nicht auf die angewandt. Also die haben, es ist wirklich ein rechtsfreier Raum. Okay. Und deswegen muss man schon sagen, also das ist natürlich, die formulieren wir vielleicht unglücklich, aber man muss schon sagen, die dürfen weitestgehend machen, was sie wollen. Und, aber spannend, dann läuft man da durch und begegnet ihnen. Und es war so, dass damals der Anführer hat, Lorenzo hieß der, er hatte ... Von eurer Truppe? Nee, der Anführer von den indigenen Kogis, dem Volk, hat irgendwann dann mit dem Entdecker des Ortes gesagt, nee, ihr könnt da hinreisen. Also Touristen, extranjeros können hinreisen, und das angucken und sozusagen unseren heiligen Ort besuchen. Wir würden uns freuen. Der jüngere Bruder, wie sie uns nennen, sie sind der ältere Bruder, wir sind der jüngere Bruder, kann da hinreisen und sich das angucken, weil sie sich auch ein bisschen freuen, dass Leute sich dafür interessieren. Es gilt aber heute nicht mehr als verflucht. Es gilt nicht mehr, ich glaube, es ist immer noch als verflucht, die leben da ja nicht, es gilt immer noch als verflucht. Ich glaube schon, es ist ein he noch was auf die leben ja nicht es gibt auch hier die flucht ich glaube schon es ist ein heiliger ort aber es hat nicht im schönen sinne ein ort an dem man sein will ja und dann reist man da reist man da durch und dann kommt man da hin an diesen ort bereist diese terrassen alles fantastisch und dann geht man oben noch weiter und da ist dann ein Indigener gewesen.
Und dann hat die Tourguide gesagt, ja, das ist, und sie hat davor schon von sehr vielen Spiritual-Leadern gesprochen, die die Kogis da haben und so, sie hat von mehreren Hundert gesprochen. und hat gesagt, hier sitzt er, Spiritual Leader, und wir alle, ja, okay, haben schon auf dem Weg ein paar gesehen, interessant, was macht er?
Und dann kam er auf uns zu, und dann hatten wir die Möglichkeit, mit ihm zu sprechen. Und dann hat er uns, aber primär, Armbänder verkaufen wollen. Und dann habe ich es natürlich gekauft. Oh, tatsächlich, ich habe mich schon gefragt, wow, ich weiß nicht, wie lange es noch hält. Es ist wirklich sehr dünn, muss man sagen. Für alle Podcast-Hörer, es ist für ein Armband sehr dünn. Es hat 2000 kolumbianische Pesos gekostet, was, glaube ich, so 50 Cent oder so sind. Ja. Und die Summen da sind generell insane, weil das ist so eine gewährte Währung. Was sind das, so kleine Perlen? Naja, so kleine Perlen. Zwei grüne, zwei Rohr. Zwei Röhr, glaub ich im Wern. Und dann ist es klein erst... Dann von den Pantheren, oder wie? Die haben die dann... Die ernten die von den... Nee, das ist einfach chinesische Plastikperlen. Die wachsen dann da im Dschungel, oder? Nee, ich glaub, die kaufen die. Ich weiss das wirklich nicht. Und die werden dann nochmal so gesegnet, so mit Geräucherstäten? Nee, die verkaufen das einfach. Okay. Nee, ich weiss das wirklich nicht. Ich hab mich auch gefragt, woher die da bekommen. Ich glaube, die sind vielleicht sogar selber gefärbt, weiß ich nicht genau. Diese Bänder sind auf jeden Fall selber aus so Baumwolle gemacht, eigener Herstellung. Okay. So abgerübenen Rinden. Aber durftest du dann auch eine Frage stellen? So, und jetzt ist es nämlich spannend gewesen, weil ich dachte auch, da hieß es nämlich, wer so ein Armband kaufen will, geht dann jetzt da hin und dann kriegt man ein Armband und dann sind das spezielle Perlen, no whatever, und dann sagt er einem was dazu. Und ich finde es natürlich, ich habe ja auch grossen Spaß an Horoskopen immer. Na klar. Ich finde es auch spannend. Ich glaube kein bisschen dran, aber ich finde es natürlich interessant, was habt ihr über mich zu sagen. Und dann kam er auf mich. Wenn es um mich geht, bin ich in der Regel interessiert.
Egal, wer über mich redet, was sagen die Engel über mich?
Ja, ne, ernsthaft, was sagen die Engel über mich?
Welche Meinung haben Engel von mir?
Nicht gläubig, aber Engel kennen meine Mann?
Ja, okay, alles klar, hör ich mir mal an, was ist deren Meinung?
Und dann hat jeder die gleiche Scheisskette bekommen und er hat bei jedem gesagt, Montagna y Flora, Berg und Blume, Berg. Und ich dachte erst, ah, ich kriege Berg und Blume und er sagt, er hat auch nicht gesagt, wofür das steht. Und was hattet ihr? Ja, auch, Montagna und Flora. Ich hatte auch Montagna und Flora. für Ich will meine 2000-Pesos zurück, was viel mehr klingt, als es ist. Das heisst, du bist seitdem auch in der inneren Reise, in der inneren Suche überlegen, was genau das für dich bedeutet, Berg und Blume. Warum hast du und alle anderen genau diesen Einsinnspruch jetzt bekommen? Was bedeutet das für Stefan Berg und Blume? Was ist das Ergebnis deiner philosophisch-spirituellen Reise zu diesen beiden Begriffen? Darüber denke ich jetzt schon wirklich seit dem Moment nach. Und ich kann jetzt nach, wie lange ist es her, drei Wochen sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung. Ah, okay. Da musst du noch länger in dich gehen. Vielleicht ist dein Geist noch nicht befreit. Nee, und dann kam es zu dem Moment, dann hieß es, jetzt könnt ihr mit ihm reden, könnt ihr eine Frage stellen. Es war alles sehr unaufgeregt anmoderiert. Es war so random guy-mässig anmoderiert.
Aber dürften auch die eine Frage stellen, die nichts gekauft haben? War das Teil des Deals oder war das jetzt einfach die spirituelle Arbeit, das hat damit nichts zu tun oder war das Teil des Deals? Ihr kriegt ein Armband, ihr kriegt einen Sinnspruch und ihr dürft eine Frage stellen. Nee, es war wirklich so, wie er durfte in Frage stellen, die Gruppe gemein wurde gefragt und er spricht auch Spanisch, nicht alle sprechen Spanisch, er spricht Spanisch, und hat die spanische Türke dann diese Frage gestellt. Wir haben dann als Gruppe, wie es so ist, hat jemand eine Frage, und es war eine prima europäische Gruppe, und alle natürlich so, und dann hat sich die Holländerin der Bahn gesagt, wie kommen sie denn in das Amt, werden sie gewählt oder wie läuft das?
Und das ist die Frage, mit der die Gruppe...
Du hast den grössten spirituellen Priester dieses gesamten Volkes vor dir. Sie hat gesagt, es gibt Hunderte und sie hat ihn nur vorgestellt als Guy und dann stehen wir da, er verkauft Bracelets, er ist offensichtlich der Gift-Shop-Guy und wir stellen die Frage, wie wurden sie gewählt und dann hat er ohne Scheiss gesagt, ne, ne, da habe ich keine Lust darüber zu reden und dann ist er gegangen und der Tourguide war verwirrt, wir waren verwirrt, alle waren verwirrt, er hat glaube ich gesagt, ich habe da keine Lust darauf zu antworten und ist dann einfach gegangen. Fair, völlig fair. So, und dann war es natürlich, am Abend war es immer so, dann hat der Tourguide uns immer noch so Geschichten erzählt, von dem Ort und so, es war richtig schön. Man fällt auch abends relativ früh ins Bett dann und ist dann, weil man es wahnsinnig viel geht, man geht halt in vier Tagen 50 Kilometer durch halt diese krasse Vegetation und Höhenmeter. Und deswegen ist man so abends um 19 Uhr einfach, wenn man noch morgens um 5 Uhr loswandert, ist man raus. So ab 20 Uhr pennen alle. Und da erzählt sie immer noch schöne gute Nachtgeschichten so. Da hat sie uns ein bisschen was von dem Tag erzählt und wer er war. Und dann kam raus, er war der fucking spiritual leader von den Kogis. Er ist der Sohn von Lorenzo, der damals überhaupt Leuten erlaubt hat, in diesen Ort zu kommen, Romaldo. Und man kann ihn googeln. Es gibt Zeitungsartikel über Romaldo.
Ist quasi der Papst. Romaldo. Und man kann den googeln. Es gibt Zeitungsartikel über Romaldo.
Er ist quasi der Papst.
Er hat wirklich, der besucht Staatsleute und hat sie uns das erzählt und wir konnten das alle nicht glauben, weil das war halt der, sie hat ihn auch nicht so richtig vorgestellt.
Sie hat gesagt, wir dachten, wir haben diese Armbänder im Kauf.
Ich meine, der hat an dem Tag 4,50 Euro verdient an euren Armbändern.
Und dann die Spanierin in der Gruppe hat dann den Satz des Trips für mich gesagt, the guy who sold bracelets. Ja, sehr schön. Und im Kern war es, the guy who sold us bracelets ist einfach der spiritual leader gewesen. Fantastisch. Von den Kobis. Und wenn du das weisst, und die haben eine super spannende, wie gesagt, nicht über alle Zweifel erhabene, menschenrechtlich, aber eine super spannende Kultur und Religion. Und die haben auch schon, es gibt natürlich so eine Doku aus den Sechzigern über die, wo die schon darüber sprechen, dass der Planet kaputt geht und die Sonne immer heisser wird und so. Also sie haben super, so krass ist es, wenn man sich das anguckt, wie schnell sie bemerkt haben, dass mit dem Planeten was nicht stimmt oder was im Wandel ist, ist alles ziemlich beeindruckend und wie sie mit dem Planeten leben und nie über ihre Bedürfnisse hinaus Dinge wollen und so. Es ist super, super spannend und kann für uns eigentlich eine so eine Lektion sein. Es war auch sehr, sehr interessant auf diesem Trip so zu bemerken, dass das auch geht. Und dann, keine Ahnung, hätten wir alle Fragen stellen können, diesem Spiritual Leader, alle Fragen, wir hätten sagen können, was rätst du uns als Europäer, die jetzt gerade damit konfrontiert sind, einer grossen Challenge, wahrscheinlich die grösste, die seit Jahrzehnten herrscht, wie kriegen wir den Planeten gerettet, was machen wir, wie leben wir, dann hätte er nicht gesagt.
Also Emissionspapiere, sowas.
Okay, gut, danke.
Sollte ich bei Lufthansa den CO2-Ausgleich zahlen? Ja. So, und dann hat man alle Fragen, die man stellen kann. Was kann ich tun? Whatever, wie, was würdest du mir raten, wie finde ich zu mir Ruhe, wie finde ich zu mir? Ich habe das Gefühl, durch unsere Eindrücke ist mir der Bezug zu mir selber verloren gegangen, meine Körperlichkeit, wie kann ich die wieder, keine Ahnung, du kannst ja irgendwie spannende, anregende, spirituelle Fragen stellen. Du wirst natürlich auch die Frage stellen können, was bedeutet Berg und Blume? Ich rätsel seit vier Minuten. Nee, Sanyo ist dann zwischendurch erklärt, es ist irgendwie Glück. Okay, na gut. Es ist das, was sie sich die ganze Zeit angucken, Blumen und Berume. Ich rätsel seit vier Minuten. Ne, das hat uns dann zwischendurch erklärt. Es ist irgendwie Glück. Es ist das, was sie die ganze Zeit angucken, Blumen und Berge. Ah ja. Aber keine Ahnung. Aber ich finde die Frage schon geil. Und dann ist die Frage, wie wurden sie gewählt und er dreht ab. Was ist, Frau Buddha ist vor dir? Ja. Frau Buddha, du kannst dir alle Fragen stellen und du sagst, wie bist du es geworden? Aber auch die Vorstellung, dass Bruder sagt, oh ne, ich hab's keine Vorstellung, ne, ich pack's, Leute, macht's gut, wir sehen uns, will noch jemand ein Armband? Aber genau so stelle ich mir Gott vor, wenn man so ein dummes Gebet dem stellt, dass er so sagt, so, and here we go, auflegen. Ja, danke! Grossartig, das ist wirklich gut. Aber auch, du hast eine Frage, du kletterst durch den eisigsten Berg, die eisigsten Gipfel für eine Frage, zu dem grossen Weisen. Und dann fragst du, wie bist du das eigentlich geworden? Wie wird man das? Also so ein typischer, hat jemand noch eine Frage? Genau. Aber er wurde auch nicht ange... Aber weiss man das denn nicht früher, dass man sich da was überlegen kann? Ich glaube, ich könnte diesen Trip nicht geniessen, wenn ich wüsste, so, wir waren jetzt drei Tage durch den Dschungel, das ist extrem beschwerlich, aber ein herrliches Naturspektakel, und dann habt ihr die Möglichkeit, dem spirituellen Führer dieses indigenen Volks eine Frage zu stellen. Die drei Tage verloren. Weil ich nur denke, okay, du brauchst eine gute Frage, du brauchst auf jeden Fall eine, du brauchst eine Backup-Frage. Falls die erste Frage schon jemand anders stellt, brauchst du eine Backup-Frage. Oh, aber was ist wenn, oh, ich brauche zwei Backup-Fragen. Und dann will ich die ganze Zeit nur darüber nachdenken, was will ich überhaupt wissen, warum mache ich das überhaupt, warum bin ich hier, kann ich mich krankstellen oder was? Ah, furchtbar, furchtbar. Ja, exakt. Aber das sind so diese... Es wurde leider nicht so angekündigt, also Gott sei Dank wurde es nicht so angekündigt, weil dann wäre ich auch die ganze Zeit mein Kopf da gewesen, wäre aber wahrscheinlich mit einer besseren Frage um die Ecke gekommen. So ist jetzt komplett, der Türkei hat es komplett verkackt, diesen Moment, finde ich, weil es wurde uns nicht gesagt, wer das ist. Wir waren alle so ein bisschen so, ja, uns werden jetzt Armbänder verkauft, süss, cool, schönes Andenken, so ein Pilgergeschenk, also Geschenk in Einführungszeichen, aber so, das Geld geht auch komplett an die Indigenen, mich spannend. Und dann hatte ich auch kompletten Aussetzer und als ich diese Bracelet bekommen habe, ich habe gedacht, ich war irgendwie so berührt, wollte mich bedanken auf eine Art. Aber die einzigen Wörter, die ich kenne, sind Muchas und Grafias, was ja reichen sollte. Mein Gehirn hat sich aber... Ja, aber das sagst du auch, wie du einen Taco kaufst. Ich weiss, aber ich weiss nicht, was heisst wie, ich fühle mich sehr geehrt, vielen Dank, weiss ich nicht. Ich weiss nur vielen Dank, vielen und Dank, oder Muchas, Muchas, Grafias, aber ich weiss nicht mal nicht mal wie das freut mich aber sehr viel keine ahnung habe ich nicht habe ich das vokabular nicht ja und mein gehirn hat sich gedacht rückwärtssalto error wie kriegen wir unsere und habe ich thank you very much gesagt wow und und er so ganz respektvoll neigt den kopf. Ich glaube, er weiss nicht, der einzige, der Spanisch spricht, ich glaube nicht, der Englisch spricht, komplett braindead. Aber ich finde, man sollte das auch überdenken mit dieser dummen Frage, hast du eine Frage so, das ist auch, wenn dann irgendwie Thomas Gottschalk kommt an die Schule oder so und erzählt, wie war es damals und dann hat noch jemand eine Frage, nein, niemand eine frage nie hat jemals jemand eine frage ich mir auch man muss immer sich was ausdenken so was was war denn die beste frage die je jemand das ist scheiss egal einfach ich denke auch wenn jemand eine Frage hat, die es wert ist zu stellen, und derjenige weiss das dann, wird die gestellt. Ja. Selbst ohne dieses Aufmachen der Runde. Aber das, finde ich, muss sich gesamtgesellschaftlich durchsetzen. Weil ich, also wirklich, ich bin da so auf so ... Da gab es mal so eine Ausstellung in Hamburg während der Corona-Zeit und dann konnte man die Ausstellung so per Zoom besuchen. Und dann war man in so einem Zoom-Call mit der Kuratorin, die hat dann so die Bilder gezeigt. Bei jedem Bild am Ende hat man das gefragt. Und dann waren halt einfach so random Leute in diesem Zoom-Call, die man nicht kannte. Einfach Leute, die das auch gebucht haben da, haben dann so ein Ticket gekauft und war dann da drin. Und dann gab es halt ständig... Und auch so einen Typ, der sonst die Bilder bewacht steht, auch im Zoom-Call drin.
Kannst du den Rucksack mit vorne rummachen?
Einfach nur fürs Museumsfeeling, ja.
Und dann wirklich auch ständig, und manche haben auch für die Kamera angemacht, das waren auch ältere Leute so, und ich halt sofort Kamera aus, Mikrofon aus, so natürlich nehme ich hier nicht teil, ich schaue nur zu.
Und dann auch ständig hat jemand eine Frage. Okay, dann hat keiner mehr eine Frage, dann gehen wir zum nächsten Bild und es war wirklich quälen einfach. Wie lange müsste sie so gucken und warten, bis alle den Zoom-Call verlassen. Wie lange würde es dauern, bis ... Wie viel Pause musste sie lassen, eine Frage zuzulassen, wie lange würde es dauern, bis alle aus dem Zoom-Call raus. Hat noch jemand eine Frage? Und dann so auch der Blick. Ja, genau. Und mit so diesem ... Irgendjemand? Und das wirklich minutenlang, 40 Minuten, 50 Minuten, 60 Minuten lang. Sie haben jetzt die Gelegenheit, Fragen zu stellen? Zwischendurch. Ja? Sie haben jetzt noch die Gelegenheit. Genau, Sie haben jetzt noch die Möglichkeit, dem Künstler Radimir Karanowitsch eine Frage zu stellen. Stell mir eine Frage. Wo ist die Frage? Ja, Sie können die Frage auch in den Chat schreiben, wenn Sie möchten. Ich bin den weiten Weg angereist. Wo ist die Frage? Ja, ich finde, es muss wirklich, es gehört zu. Aber ich finde, wenn man fragt, hat jemand eine Frage, wirklich acht Sekunden. Nein! Hat jemand eine Frage? Zoom, Delay und dann drei Sekunden. Hat jemand eine Frage? Leute, die eine Frage haben, würden sofort sich melden, weil wer hat noch eine Frage? Und eine Frage, über die du erst nachdenkst, sobald jemand fragt, ob man eine Frage hat, die ist eh schlecht. Die ist auch unauthentisch. Das ist keine Frage, das ist Selbstzweck. Nee, ich finde, die ist nicht unbedingt schlecht. Die ist schon schlecht, weil du, nee, weil du das nur, nee, Fragen, die du nur stellst, um eine Frage zu stellen, sind schlecht. Nee, es geht nicht, nein, es geht nicht um die Qualität der Frage, finde ich. Da können auch clevere Leute mit sehr guten Fragen schnell um die Ecke kommen, wenn aufgefordert wird. Die sind nur fucking unauthentisch und das macht so kacke. So, wenn ich ja vorne stehe und interviewt werde gerade und dann wird das der Floor geöffnet für Fragen und dann sagt jemand hat noch eine Frage und dann ist Pause, Pause, Pause und irgendwann hitt jemand aus Höflichkeit in der Hand, selbst wenn die Frage gut ist, denke ich mir, ja, interessiert ja offensichtlich niemanden. Ja, ja, das ist so, wie wenn irgendjemand an die Schule kommt und da irgendwas vorträgt, irgendwie ich war im Gefängnis oder so, lasst euch nicht auf Drogen ein und dann habt ihr noch Fragen und der Lehrer hat dann noch Fragen. Das ist dann so, ja, okay, aber du, so, natürlich, du hast aus Höflichkeit noch Fragen, aber die Kinder interessiert es nicht. Und das genau, was ich jetzt gerade gesagt habe, ist das Problem. Dass du keine Frage heisst, heisst nicht, dass dich der Vortrag nicht interessiert oder du ihn nicht interessant fandest. Das heisst es nicht. Es ist kein Zeichen von Interesse, wenn noch Fragen offen sind. Du kannst dir das einfach angucken. Es ist einfach okay. Du schaust eine Doku an und du hast keine Fragen, sondern du hörst zu. Okay, alles klar, das ist Ägypten, okay, tu dir nicht an, haben wir. Komplett Recht. Komplett, ich unterstreiche das dreifach. Und wir sollten uns da gesamtgesellschaftlich verändern. Aber wenn ein Spiritual Leader aus einer anderen Welt zu dir kommt und du hast die Chance, eine Frage zu stellen, stell eine gute Frage. Wirklich. Das ist ein super spannender Kulturen-Aufeinandertreffen-Moment. Das ist total cool.
Aber eigentlich kannst du, weil ich glaube, das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist, du assimilierst dann irgendwie so diesen Stil.
Du sagst dann, oh, edler, weiser Anführer.
Weiser, weiser.
Weiser, was sagt der Baum zum Sonnenuntergang?
So, weil du dir denkst, so, das ist bestimmt die Art von Frage, die dann irgendwie da so funktioniert.
Man muss auch wieder erprobieren.
Einfach so.
Das ist auch aufrichtig eine Frage.
Was für eine aufrichtige Frage hast du denn?
Was ist das Wichtigste im Leben?
Ja, ich finde es einfach spannend, was deine Aufmerksamkeit ist.
Berg und Blume, haben wir doch schon gesagt, du Depp.
Warum sage ich das denn? Wie oft soll ich noch sagen? Berg und Blume, haben wir doch schon gesagt, du Depp! Warum sag ich das denn? Wie oft soll ich noch sagen? Berg und Blume! Berg und Blume! Berg und Blume! Also auch immer eine tolle Frage. Mit welchen zwei Begriffen? Nee, ich finde es nicht. Ich finde, du kannst, vielleicht fällt mir ein Duktus, okay, fair enough, aber ich finde nicht, dass du eine Frage stellen musst, wo es dann irgendwie, du übernimmst dann plötzlich das Spirituelle. Nein, ich finde es einfach spannend, was der Mensch gesagt hätte auf die Frage, wie finde ich zu mir oder whatever. Ich finde es einfach, jetzt nicht, weil ich es unbedingt anwenden will, ich finde einfach diesen Einblick, nach dieser Logik würdest du ja gar keine Doku gucken wollen, ever, über eine andere Zivilisation. Ich finde aber, es gibt ja noch diese Frage, die eigentlich keine Frage ist, sondern eigentlich nur eine Aufforderung, erzähl noch mal mehr. So diese klassische, ja, Herr Gottschalk, meine Frage ist, was ist denn das Peinlichste, was Ihnen jemals in der Sendung passiert ist? So, das ist keine Frage. Du willst einfach, dass die Person noch mehr erzählt. Das ist das Coolste, was dir niemand mit dir gehört hat.
So, genau, so, was ist schon mal das Mikrofon ausgegangen? So, ich will einfach noch eine Geschichte hören. Eine Rampe auf eine Anekdote. Genau, aber man hat keine Frage. Das ist ja, glaube ich, der Mittelweg, den man sich dann auch oft nimmt, ist dann einfach so, erzähl bitte noch mehr. Du bist ja interessant, erzähl noch mal mehr. Ja, nee, ich finde, man hätte da durchaus eine coole Frage stellen können. Es hätte einen coolen Moment geben können, man hätte irgendwie Einblick bekommen können in diese Zivilisation. Ich glaube auch, du hättest, wollen Sie wirklich, wir erleben mit dem Auto nicht leichter. Warum finden Sie? Also könnten Sie nicht mehr von den Armbändern verkaufen, wenn Sie mit einem Auto von einer heiligen Stätte zur anderen fahren?
Dann sind Sie ja schneller, könnten Sie mehr verkaufen. Ja, und viel Spaß, wie Sie Auto erklärt. Und dann auch, was... Er hat einen Zeigen, Auto auf dem Handy. Was kein schöner Moment gewesen wäre, aber ein spannender Moment wäre, wenn jemand gefragt hätte, warum finden Sie hier Männer und Frauen nicht die gleichen rechte verdient ja okay und dann wird
es eine endlose diskussion wo am ende auseinander geht okay ich glaube wir haben ja
einfach unterschiedliche meinungen es hätte genauso geändert wie es bei uns geändert hat er
gesagt ich will darauf nicht antworten und es wäre gegangen sagt er einfach auf alles ist ist
das seine art weil du ich glaube es ist also ich könnte diese position und die wird mir oft
zugesprochen als spiritueller anführer, als intelligenter Mensch, als ja, ja, universal finde ich so. Und natürlich kommen zu mir viele Pilgerer, ja, die Fragen haben. Und eigentlich. Wer zuletzt? Ich bin kein Pilgerer, ne, nur weil ich aus Köln komme gerade. Das war eine Art Pilgerreise. Nee, es war keine Pilgerreise, es war eine berufliche Reise. Das war eine Art Pilgerreise, weil du mich sehen wolltest.
Weil du mit mir dich unterhalten wolltest, weil du Orientierung brauchst im Leben, weil du wie ein Kompass, der seinen Norden verloren hat, von mir eingepolt werden möchtest. Das ist auch in Ordnung. Aber da ist natürlich ein enormer Druck drauf. Und deswegen kannst du ja oft einen mysteriöseren Umhang dir umliegen, wenn du einfach sagst, nee, mit der Frage möchte ich mich gerade nicht beschäftigen. Ja, ich finde das irgendwie auch Arbeitsverweigerung. Weil als Spiritual Leader muss er ja antworten. Ja, für dich ist es wie so ein Automat. Du wirfst die Münze ein und dann die Pepsi-Dose kommt nicht. Naja, fucking Bracelets. Aber ich muss sagen, es stimmt schon. Also ich fand es irgendwie auf eine Art, fand ich es einen coolen, so einen Mic-Drop-Moment, weil er so gesagt hat, ach, ist mir alles so, diese weltliche Frage.
Ich habe wirklich, ich habe 50 Coca-Blätter in meinem Mund und kau darauf rum seit Tagen. Ich habe die beste Zeit gerade, ich will mich da hinten hinsetzen, auf diesem Stein, auf dem ich gerade sass, bevor ihr meine Ruhe gestört habt. Und ich fand es aber auch irgendwie cool, dass er so hat, dass er so hat. Ich kann mir das, ich wäre, glaube ich, so verführt, den zu verführen. Und dann einfach so, bevor wir gehen, sage ich, ja. Und dann schenke ich ihm so einen Game Boy. Mit Batterien, die lange halten, einfach Super Mario 1, Game Boy. Einfach so, ne, ich gebe den einfach mal. Und dann ich mir vorstellen, in zwei Wochen irgendwie Schlagzeile, hat sein Amt niedergelegt, Heisscore geknappt, knapp oder so. Also wir beide, die gemeinsam waren, haben uns die Frage gestellt, wenn man einen Laptop hätte und auf dem darfst du eine Datei haben. Das war der Grossteil der Diskussion auf dem Weg dahin.
Was genau ist eine Datei?
Welche Datei, glaubst du, würde die Zivilisation am schnellsten beenden?
Eight Mile.
Der Film Eight Mile.
Ja, acht, acht Komma vier Gigabyte, Eight Mile ist, glaube ich, Punkt, wo … Ich war auch beim Film … so etwas wie Ace Ventura. Weil was passiert dann? Keine Chance, dass er nur einmal geguckt wird. Selbst wenn er dir nicht gefallen hat, ich glaube, du guckst ihn irgendwann nochmal. Es ist der einzige Film. Es ist der einzige Film, den du hast. Und allein, dass du einen Film hast, ist ja schon mal interessant. Der erste Film war ja auch nicht interessant, war ja dieser Zug oder so. Du denkst, ja, die haben alle schon mal einen Zug gesehen, die in dem Kino sassen. Das finde ich eine spannende Frage. Ja. Was ist der, welches Buch würde am ehesten sagen, dass alle sagen, so, wir lassen es. Wir lassen es. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer, aber zu sagen, entweder wir lassen das hier, was wir hier gerade machen, oder kein Vertrauen mehr in die Welt oder so, finde ich eine spannende Frage. Oh Mann, ich fände das so reizvoll, ich fände das wirklich so reizvoll, dem einfach irgendwie so einen Song auf dem Handy vorzuspielen, einfach so, wie finden sie das? Auch ein bisschen so ein Kongressatoren-Mindset, ne? Ja, klar. Ich glaube, das war schon, man kommt nicht raus. Du bist ja neidisch. Also, wenn du wirklich einen Menschen vor dir hast, der glücklich ist, wenn er in seinem Wald sitzt, das macht dich ja wütend. Also du denkst dir, never ever könnte ich in einem Wald sitzen und das auch nur im Ansatz in Ordnung finden. Ich bin so kaputt, ich habe so eine geringe Aufmerksamkeit. Du willst den zerstören. Natürlich willst du den zerstören, auf eine Art. Du willst, dass der genauso auf deine Dopaminsucht runtergezogen wird wie du auch. Dann gibt es ihm Gummibärchen, Zucker, Jeans, Konsum, Musik, Unterhaltung, du willst, dass der auch kaputt geht, genauso wie du kaputt gemacht wurdest von dieser kaputten Welt. Und dann sagst du, ah, die Skinny-Jeans, die vor zwei Jahren noch modern waren oder die sich sie sich gerade gewöhnt haben. Weg, ouch, hat man nicht mehr, hat man nicht mehr jetzt hier bitte baggy weite Hosen. Baggy Boots. Ich musste alles neu kaufen. Ja, das ist komplett. Aber es kommt mir, dieser Trend kommt mir wirklich zugute. Weite Hosen, liebe ich, ich liebe diesen Trend. Wegen deines Gemächts. Wegen meines irren Riesengemächtes … Irre.
Und dann wegen meiner allgemeinen Grosswüchsigkeit ist es natürlich … Ich sehe aus wie ein langer Lulatsch.
Und meine Beine sehen aus wie lange Spinnenbeine.
Ja, aber weil du die auch immer so angewinkelt, so breitbeinig angewinkelt, so durch die Gänge ziehst.
Ist ja auch nicht immer leicht.
Nee, und deswegen, jetzt um alles in Proportion zu rücken, finde ich, breite Hosen machen meinen Körper auf weiter Entfernung, sehe ich aus wie ein normal grosser Mensch jetzt. Und das gefällt mir gut. Deswegen mache ich diesen Trend sehr, aber ich fürchte mich, jeden Tag mache ich meinen Laptop, klappe ich auf, betend, in der Hoffnung, dass jetzt nicht so steht, wieder Skinny Jeans, wir tragen wieder nur Skinny Jeans.
Schlagzeile Skinny Jeans wieder in. Ich finde das so spannend, weil natürlich will die Fashion-Industrie immer weitergehen, natürlich. Ich verstehe nur nicht, wie das funktioniert, dass man immer wieder was Neues will. Weil man fand das ja alles mal gut. Ja, ja. Du bist jetzt nicht so im Fashion-Game drin wahrscheinlich. Ich bin nicht so im Fashion-Game drin, aber ich denke mir schon ... Trends, warum, ich bin so anfällig für Trends, und du ja auch, vielleicht nicht für Fashion-Trends, aber du bist für andere Trends anfällig. Ja, ich finde es ja auch interessant, dass alles irgendwann bescheuert aussieht. Also egal wie cool auch so vom Design her irgendwie dann so minimalistisches Design. Und du denkst dir, ich finde, das sieht richtig cool aus. So eine coole Webseite von irgendeiner edlen Marke oder so, denkst du, die Schrift und so, das alles cool. Aber ich denke mir immer, in 30 Jahren sieht das richtig albern aus. Ausser alle Braunprodukte und alle Apple-Produkte sind immer noch und es gab kein Jahr. Also diese Tangerine-orange-Computer und so, die sind schon ikonisch, das sind designikonisch, aber die sind heute schon ein bisschen albern. Man kann nicht sagen, sind sie einfach nur ikonografisch oder wirklich noch schick. Deswegen, und der einzige Mensch auf der Welt, der diese Frage beantworten kann, ist der Spiritual Leader auf seinem Hügel. Romaldo. Du musst diesen Computer sagen und sagst, ist das, weil der hat ja keine Zeit, der hat ja keine Mode, der hat ja keine Trends. Der kann einfach nur ästhetisch rein die Form bewerten. Und dann musst du sagen, ist das ein schöner Computer? der erste iMac-Tangerine, wo man hinten noch so ins Plastik, in das Gehäuse reingucken kann, ist das eine gute Idee, sollten wir alles durchsichtig machen oder nicht? Warum du auf diesem Trip, wo man wenig Gepäck mitnehmen sollte und möglichst sich auf den Basic beschränken sollte. Ja, den iMac hatte, der einen Griff hatte. Früher hatten solche Rechner alle einen Griff und selbst das erste der, das erste Macbook, das man ja kennt, Legally Blonde zum Beispiel, wo sie dieses Macbook hat, das dann so bunt ist und alle anderen haben so diese schwarzen Laptops und so, der hatte sogar noch einen Griff, der hatte unten am Scharnier, hatte der noch so einen, den konntest du so ausklappen, einen Griff und dann hatte der wirklich so einen Henkel, an dem du den tragen konntest, weil man damals wahrscheinlich noch nicht so, weil man dachte, Laptops, die brauchen natürlich so einen Henkel, den trägst du wie einen Koffer und nicht einfach unter dem Arm. Hat sich nicht durchgesetzt, aber. Ja, und dann hättest du diese Frage gestellt und hat er gesagt, er kaut nämlich wirklich die ganze Zeit Kuckablätter, die die Frauen gesammelt haben, die selber keine nehmen dürfen.
Hat er gesagt auf diese Frage, alle hätten sich in Grund und Boden geschämt, wie dieser Tacky Guy, der die ganze Zeit mit seinem Mac rumgelaufen ist, und dann hat er gesagt,
Montagna, wie Flora, wie Apple. Oh! Hast du auch Koka-Blätter genascht? Was ist das überhaupt? Also ist das so Kokain? Also kommt daher, ist das so das Ding? Ja, Kokain kommt, das ist der synthetisierte Wirkstoff von Koka-Blättern. Das heisst, wenn du das kaust, ist das so leicht, so wie so ein Kokain-Kaugummi so ein bisschen. Gut, spürt nichts. Ja, in Peru habe ich es häufiger gemacht. In Peru hatte man die ganze Zeit Coca-Blätter im Mund, um klarzukommen mit der Höhe, weil dann wirklich das Blut ein bisschen mehr Sauerstoff aufnehmen kann. Aber da gab es das jetzt gar nicht. Aber was ist das? Also kannst du das... Ich stelle mir vor, warum kannst du das so lange kauen? Hat man es nicht irgendwann einfach dann gegessen? Man hat es einfach durch, dann spuckt man es an den Boden und steckst dir den Meer rein. Ah, okay. Aber du zerkaustest und dann... Und dann musst du ausspucken. Sonst kriegst du wie bei allen anderen Sachen da in Kolumbien die Scheisserei. So, und jetzt kommen wir zu dem Thema, das mich wirklich interessiert. Wie war das Essen? Essen ist tatsächlich... Kolumbien ist kein Foodie-Land. Ach was. Nein, nein, nein, nein, viel frittiertes Zeug, aber das Essen auf diesem Trip war wirklich das Beste auf der ganzen Reise, diese vier Tage, weil da war es richtig cool, so richtig frischen Fisch auf dem Teller, richtig lecker, Reis, habe ich gemocht, sonst kein Foodie-Land. Und du wurdest gar nicht entführt? Hattest du überhaupt keinen Kontakt mit der Drogenszene? Bei Kolumbien und so denke ich natürlich an Pablo Escobar und sowas. Nee, das Land ist seit 20 Jahren nicht wieder zu erkennen. Es ist crazy, die hat richtig gut in den Griff bekommen. Auch gerade so Medellin und so, die Hauptstadt von Pablo Escobars Drogenkartell damals, wird nicht vor 20 Jahren gefährliche Stadt, auch durch Pablo Escobar, wahnsinnig viel Scheisse da passiert, wahnsinnig viele zehntausend Zivilisten gestorben durch diese ganzen Narcos-Banden und so. Und jetzt einfach, die hatten einen richtig coolen Politiker zwischendurch am Start, wahrscheinlich mehrere, die wirklich so gesagt haben, nee, man kann Kriminalität nicht mit Strafen begegnen, sondern es macht nur Sinn, das mit besseren Alternativen wie sozialen Strukturen, was auch immer, Arbeitsmöglichkeiten und so weiter entgegenzuwirken. Und dann haben die diese Masiertaktik, haben die das wirklich gut hinbekommen. Und Medellin, glaube ich, wird seit ein paar Jahren so zur innovativsten Stadt der Welt gewählt, weil es da immer viel passiert, auch eine U-Bahn-Netz hat und so. Es ist schon eine coole Stadt. Krass, okay. Und ehrlich gesagt, deswegen hassen die das auch, auf diese ganze Narcos-Sache reduziert zu werden. Achso, die finden das gar nicht cool. Gar nicht cool. Ja. Ja, wiederum, glaube ich, gibt es auch wahnsinnig viele Leute, die das wahnsinnig cool finden, aber viele haben dann wahrscheinlich auch noch böse Erinnerungen dran, weil es halt noch nicht so lange her ist. Ja, ja, das muss man immer, ja. Und wenn man halt die ganze Zeit sagt, wann kann man endlich Kuckablätter in den Mund stecken, Plata e Plomo, habe ich auf Netflix gesehen, au au au au au. Genau, dann sagen die, ähm, ja. Ja, nee, es war schrecklich. Ich will diese Frage, ja, genau. Es war schrecklich. Und die Antwort ist Plomo da am Ende. Ja, genau. Oder ich hab halt je nach, also meine Mutter. Ja, Peppa hat viele Familienmitglieder verloren an diese Kriege. Alle quasi. Hatte sonst noch jemand eine Frage? Nein? Okay, dann beenden wir es hier. Gut. Muchas gracias. Wenn ihr da draußen noch eine Frage habt, dann bitte stellt sie uns dann doch einfach nicht. Genau. Und bitte, verkneift euch bitte Fragen, auf deren Antwort offensichtlich Berg und Blume ist. Das brauchen wir nicht, das müssen wir nicht nochmal sagen, das haben wir jetzt oft genug gesagt, deswegen glaube ich, haben wir das auch. Und dann nochmal, Fragen, auf die ihr schon eine Antwort habt, sind keine Fragen. Richtig. Es ist bloß luftleere
Semantik.
Stefan Tietze, meine Damen und Herren.
Und in diesem Sinne, da draußen,
wenn ich euch eins mitgeben kann für die nächste Woche,
dann sind es zwei Wörter.
Montagne,
Yflora. Schöne Woche.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Macht's gut.
Ciao.
It's the worst Bird production. Nächstes Mal, mach's gut.